are you I feel like you're not a sports
guy is yoga sport no that's an activity
are you a sports guy yeah it looks much
I love sport yeah that's the 30% trying
to come no I sorry God I played in
college except this is the experience
that I would have I go to Fenway Park
one game Sox get blown out me and my
mother hiked back to the car and she
goes oh my God look and there's like a
gold Grand Cherokee at a red light and
she goes that's Dwight Evans and in the
nine oh do I have an image in the
driver's seat I'm like it is she was
yeah go get his autograph okay I'm like
all right I'm like nine I go up to the
window of his automobile at an
intersection knock on the glass he rolls
the window down Dewey Dewey mind you
he's wearing a Red Sox t-shirt and he's
sweaty looks like he just took a shower
and I go heroes on them we go to yeah I
go you're Dwight Evans can I get your
autograph because I'm not Dwight Evans
and roll up the whip it was Dwight Evans
I'm a Muslim what happened did you get
it and was ignited their affiliation was
all right friended that when he saw Eric
Clapton in a coffee shop and was like I
don't want to bother you mr. cotton is
like I'm not Eric Clapton like it's like
so obviously Harry clubbed me like no
sorry oh
playing Leila you've been misinformed
okay we're all off